чи немає брекситу не ви значущості зможуть
ним президентом франції ангела меркель
шуко та знайдених партнерів у євросоюзі
візит канцлер кайф оренду варшава
експерт роз'їдається ми у тему контексті
у нас дивлячись на низ курс бізнес і
між нинішню владу у Польщі тис місія
меркель чоловіки просто років нести з
великого вже давно правда де кого ти
більше роль у його чаю у брексит шанс
для тегу польша хочеш щоб парламенту
україни україна не в малюків пливу на у
хвала незаконена в євросоюзі
прикладом вранці цієї правова теж диво
відбутися єврокомісії цим предложением
досі ще в ньому і чині спростив іскри ну і
пандори обліку до реформи можуть повністю
паралізувати роботу з біженцем більше
Петро йому я не машину в тому що за
зовнішню кордони потрібно захищати і
видно локальну імміграцію путін в
харчуванні всередині шнива розпаду гу біженців
загарчав вони заспівали ноти варшава до товариша
на відьом є до піруват і польський
уряд покривається мігрантам з України за
офіційну статистику я тут на трошки
та 3 мільйони українців вугіллям на травень
ресурсів обидва прийняти ще більше біженців
однак початку конфлікту в Україні
чути четверо span від 5 тисяч
українців шуко рахунок прогулянку вранці або
у польщі статус біженця htc
економічні мігранти обидва студенти та
keys європейську україну біженців на
миє нічого спинного
проти пошуки равлик малюється в посмішкою
петренко і ґвалтівника виступаючи проти
біженців мусульман як їм уже за дружать
і вистачить біженцям тут потрібно нам самим
хліва шлюбу я плутала baci не говорять
чавуни відривати вас кущів на житло
у гаю не за рахунок роботи вниз до неї
апінян чіплятися
руси хану замки ранку багатих на шию іншому
у польші мишкою лише один вид
соток іноземців
права людини внутрішня політика варшави
так вже ви спочиваєте партія право і
справедливість
що представляючи на нього кунів chateau
закон удача владу в Польщі допомагаєте
взяті під контроль по суті їжі на
назвеш але видно і головну інституцію
конституційні суд та духів я з
подівся що канцлер до ангелів р к і
зможе парку нато пошуки уряд їстівний
нашим основним цінностям nike їх
утворюється е100 європа
верховенства права наша головна цінність
єврокомісія дала варшаві годину до 20
польшу валютах на жаль право таємниці далекі від
зупинено в рожевих оздобленнях права в
краю ним на спрут відомо що хну
лосята куш inci реформи правлю чую
партії пройдуся їм поваги до прав
журналістів цинічні шляхи 2 год 1с упп
ручками шпор шу то негайну розбір
але я сяду школу первинному потоку 2 що
моя паста чат і газ з Росії дошкуляти
чини по дну балтійського моря розум і навчи
транзит через українську порчу буде витрат
ця роль пуста чайна kotova намагайся
ходжу віза важливості вид росії
коли беру як би русія було
демократичну україну звивинам ринком
ми б нічого не малий просто первинного
стелі не було б проблем варшави
згорнулася а з протестом до європейського
суду у люксембурзі